une équipe de France pour briller à
domicile ce mardi 4 octobre la sélection
pour les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste est tombé les
spectateurs présents en Vélodrome
national du 12 au 16 octobre pourront
voir les têtes d'affiche française comme
Ryan et la Sébastien vigie ou encore
Mathilde gros ça va être quelque chose
de top donc je me dis voilà j'ai hâte on
a encore quelques jours pour pour
peaufiner les derniers réglages et après
bah se lancer et tout donner devant le
public la famille les amis moi j'ai fait
les Europe ici en 2016 mais il y avait
pas pas les tribunes pleines donc ça
sera un premier premier championnat
domicile avec 6000 personnes derrière
moi derrière nous même pour l'équipe de
France on retrouvera également dans
cette équipe de France trois membres du
club local de 50 ans en Yvelines le VCE
SkyTeam vous sert avec Timmy Gillion
Quentin Lafargue et Clara
copponiative du club du coup même si bah
j'ai pas l'occasion de les voir beaucoup
c'est encore plus satisfaisant que de
qui de me dire qu'ils vont être là et
qui vont me voir à la maison et en
Championnat du Monde c'est c'est cool en
termes de médailles les instances n'ont
pas voulu chiffrer d'objectifs pour ce
rendez-vous yvelinois mais l'équipe de
France semble armée pour cet événement
on est dans des disciplines qu'on
maîtrise où on a des favoris de
certaines épreuves et surtout on va
courir à domicile encouragé par on
l'espère un public nombreux et
communiquant de prendre plaisir à
prendre plaisir alors c'est quelque
chose d'important mais il faut pas se
prendre la tête ou se mettre plus de
pression le gros du travail comme je
leur ai dit il a été fait dans l'année
donc il y a une bonne préparation et
après ben faudra faudra en découdre le
jour J pour ce rendez-vous le vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines affiche
presque complet 25000 personnes sur cinq
jours vont pousser cette équipe de
France